in the movie she was a person a human
being that was alive yes she died and
now she's back but she's now in an alien
life form she looks like an alien no she
looks like herself so right watching the
movie like is she an alien or all right
what's going on yeah yeah yeah and so
what when she died and alien was
observing her and goes I want that body
that's kind of what it said because uh I
think the alien is on Earth to like
observe like grieving oh
oh that's great that that sounds like a
Star Trek yeah a Next Generation concept
yeah yeah yeah they had there was one
episode where um Deanna Troy is the
ship's counselor she's half beta said
and she um I love this and beta says
they're um telepathic what do they look
like that's not the human regular they
look Greek yeah okay there's a bunch of
Greek people yeah yeah they're like
black curly hair yeah hairy arms I know
they never showed those shots in the
[__] thing but I assume yes but
anyway she's sleeping on the um the
Enterprise and a little tiny light right
it's like going through space it's like
a little life form and it goes oh look
at the ship so it goes into the ship
sees her sleeping This little light and
he goes inside her
and she wakes up what through what orif
is yeah it's television yeah I know I
want to see it I know I know me too
probably the [__] Greek [__]
damn I went through the Greek [__] she
got it which is a lot of hair to go
through I know it's a forest right he
couldn't get in there but he finally
gets in there good she wakes up pregnant
oh he did go through the [__] the
little light came inside her that's
weird that's weird right she's pregnant
and then but the pregnancy is accelerate
accelerated oh so three days in she
gives birth
[Laughter]
yes so and then the baby is born and in
a week he grows to be 15. oh damn 16 and
then he leaves but before he leaves he
turns back into a life form and goes in
her mind and goes I just wanted to
experience
what's it like being raped
yeah you know that little light bulb the
voice was Cosby
oh because she was sleeping she was
sleeping damn yeah yeah
wow in fact if you turn up the volume
right in this that episode you hear the
light bulb go hey hey yeah he says hey
okay I'm trying to think of how
like how does Bill cos he's gonna spend
a while since I've heard him talk yeah
yeah yeah so anyway get me a great
sleepy great [__]
so so my point is that episode is to say
kind of saying because he's you know
this little alien life form is living as
a human or a human humanoid and it goes
okay I get it I love you guys you guys
are great and I'm gonna move on to a
different right so the same time go get
another one
right and also as being a little light
you know I mean like you could probably
rape easy yeah
right you can go in and out of doors and
and walls because that's what it can do
oh you can right the weight rape whistle
wait she blows a rape whistle and the
organs go Boop gone I can't even feel it
though but he's like swimming through
the Rouge of her vagina
part on the inside but that's actually a
medical term
[Laughter]
I've never heard of that body part